i've been asked to make a video on
algebraic division or algebraic long
division so i'll make a video on
algebraic long division so let's say we
wanted i'm just going to make up a
problem let's say we wanted to divide we
wanted to see how many times does i'll
start with a fairly straightforward
problem how many times does
2
x
plus 1
go into
i don't know
let's say it's
eight
x to the third
minus
seven x squared
plus
ten
x
minus five
so what we do is we just take actually
just this exact same way that you would
do with long division traditional long
division of multiple digits
you would and the 2x plus one expression
you look at oh what is the highest
degree term and that's really all we're
going to pay attention to most of the
time so the first step is you say okay
the highest degree term is 2x
how many times does 2x go into the
highest degree term of the number or not
the number the expression that we're
dividing into
so you say how many times does 2x go
into 8x to the third
well we could do a little division on
the side but you could imagine
eventually this is pretty
straightforward so if you have 8x
to the third divided by 2x that is equal
to
4
x squared right so 2x goes into 8x to
the third 4x squared times
and and this is a key thing you don't
want to write the 4x squared here you
want to keep everything in the correct
places so when you're dividing numbers
you think of the ones the tens the
hundreds and the thousands place et
cetera when you're dividing polynomials
you can kind of think of the x to the
zero space the x to the one space or the
x base the x squared space the x to the
third space so when we say that 2x goes
into 8x to the third
4x squared times
let's write that in the x squared spot
it goes into it 4
x squared
times
now
we take that 4x squared and we multiply
it by our expression i think you're
already seeing that this is very similar
to long division and actually if x was a
10 it would be identical to long
division
and i'll let you think about that right
if x was 10 this would be the thousands
place this would be 8 000 minus although
you would have negative
digits which doesn't make a bunch of
sense but i think you get what i'm
saying but anyway back to this this this
uh
this algebraic long division although i
think it is very important to see the
parallels between this and traditional
long division well anyway we said that
2x goes into 8x to the third 4x squared
times now what we can do is we can
multiply 4x squared times 2x plus 1. so
4x squared times 1
that's 4x squared so we can write that
in the x squared's position place we
could write it 4x squared
and 4x squared times 2x
is eight x to the third
eight
x to the third this is a plus here
and now just like we do with traditional
long division we can subtract this from
this
so
minus seven x squared minus 4x squared
is
minus
11
x
squared
minus 11x squared and then 8x to the
third minus ax to the third is zero so
we can ignore that right there and if we
want we can bring down the rest of uh we
can bring down the rest of the number
but maybe just for fun we'll bring down
the next spot just like we do in
traditional long
division and actually let me
erase this over here
let me erase this because i think we
might find this that real estate useful
all right i'm back
actually it doesn't actually it's it
doesn't hurt to bring down the whole
thing just so that you understand what
we what we're doing
we're saying if you were to divide 2x
plus 1 into this entire expression and
you say it goes in 4x squared times now
our i can you could kind of call our
intermediate remainder is what's left
right this is what's left you could
almost imagine 4x squared times 2x plus
1 is
this is 8x to the third plus 4x squared
plus
0 plus 0 right because it doesn't
contribute any things to these spots
but then what's left over is this
expression if you take this minus this
whole expression you get what's left
over
now we just do the same thing over how
many times does 2x we just look at the
highest order term how many times does
2x go into
negative 11
x squared so let's use let's do
something let's write it here on the
side again actually let me do it here
so if we were to take minus
11
x squared
divided by 2x that is equal to what that
is equal to minus
11 halves
x
right
so 2x goes into minus 11x squared
minus 11 11 halves x times
so we'll write that in our x place so
minus
11 halves we could write that as 5.5 if
that well let's write it as a fraction
minus 11 halves x
and now what is
minus 11 halves x times 2x plus 1. so
minus 11 halves x times 1
is minus 11 halves x and we'll want to
write that in the x position i'll switch
colors just to not be
monotonous so minus 11 half x times 1 is
minus
11
halves
x
and then minus 11 halves x times 2x
well we should know what that is but if
you can multiply them out it'll be minus
11x squared
minus 11x squared and i think you see
what we're doing after every step we're
canceling out the largest degree of the
polynomial we're dividing into
fair enough now let's subtract this
expression from this
and we'll get kind of our new
intermediary remainder and maybe that'll
be the full remainder
so let's see minus 11 x squared minus 11
x squared that's zero so we have to
write anything there
10 x
minus
negative 11 halves x remember we're
subtracting this negative number from
10x so if you're subtracting a negative
number it's like adding a positive
number right so you could view this as
10
plus 11 halves right so 10 plus 11
halves that's 20 halves plus 11 halves
that's 31 halves or 15.5 i'll just write
31 halves x
31 over 2 x
and then you could say that there was a
zero here and when you subtract zero
from minus five you get minus five
and now we say
how many times does 2x go into 31 halves
x
let's do a little work on the side here
so if i have 31 over 2
x
divided by
2x well the x's will just cancel out
right
and so this is the same thing as
this is equal to 31 over 4 right this is
the same thing as 31 over 2 times one
half so 31 over 4.
so 2x goes into this expression 31 over
four times and i'll switch colors
switch to green
so and that's a positive right you're
dividing a positive into a positive so
plus 31 over four times and i'm writing
that in the you could view that in the
constant space or the x to the zero
space
or the one space even so it goes into 31
over four times
31 over four times one
is 31 over four
31 over 4. and 31 over 4 times 2x
is 31 over 2x right
31 over 2x
and now we subtract this is a plus here
we subtract the green expression from
the light blue expression and we're left
with this when you subtract this from
this you're left with zero so we nothing
shows up there and we're left with
minus five
minus 31 over 4 and we can just do a
little bit of fraction work here that's
equal to
see minus 5 over 4 is minus 20
minus 31
all of that over 4. so minus so that is
equal to what
minus 20 that's equal to minus 51
minus 51
over 4.
so our answer is 2x plus 1
goes into 8x to the third minus seven x
squared plus ten x minus five it goes
into it four x squared minus eleven
halves x plus thirty one over four times
but there is a remainder and this is the
remainder
and so a way to visualize this or
another way to think about this problem
just so that we don't
so it's actually useful in when we're
actually solving real problems and that
you just don't view this as some kind of
mechanical way to to get problems right
on a test that only tests algebraic long
division
as another way to write this
relationship you could write that let me
do it in another color let's see have i
used i've used many of my colors already
so you could write that
2x
plus 1 times this
4
x squared that's an x
minus
11 halves
x
plus
31 over 4 plus the remainder
so when you multiply these two out and
then if you were to add the remainder 51
over 4 that that would equal and let me
draw a dividing line i don't want to
confuse you with all this stuff here
that would equal this
that would equal eight x to the third
minus seven x squared plus ten x
minus five
anyway i hope that helps see in the next
video